hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your math score
improve your understanding and hopefully
make math more fun and less stressful so
in this video we're going to talk about
is how to calculate standard deviation
by hand okay so you can do this on your
calculator and I might do a video on
that but for this video we're gonna talk
about how to actually calculate standard
deviation by hand so first of all what
is standard deviation the standard
deviation gives you an idea about how
spread out the data points are from the
mean okay from the average larger the
standard deviation the more the data
points are spread out the smaller the
standard deviation the closer the data
points are grouped together so that
gives you an overview about standard
deviation but here's the form that we're
going to be using so Sigma the Greek
letter here Sigma tells you what the
standard deviation is X sub I is each
one of our individual data points X bar
okay this means the mean or the average
okay have your data and is the number of
data points okay that you're working
with okay and and then this Sigma Greek
letter Sigma here is the sum okay so
this is your finding the sum of all the
data points okay well in this case
you're finding the sum of all the
deviations squared okay so let's go
ahead and do an example so find the
standard deviation of the following quiz
scores five eight eight nine and ten
okay so just imagine that you had five
people they took a quiz let's say it was
a 10 point quiz these are their scores
somebody did great somebody did not so
great but you want to just get an idea
about what the standard deviation is
this is a small amount of data just to
illustrate how to go through and do this
so what I would do this is how I
normally do it is I make a table okay so
here's our table looks something like
this okay so I'm going to list all the
data points which are five eight eight
nine and ten okay then we're going to
take each data point that's these here
minus the mean okay and then what we're
going to do is we're going to take each
of those standard deviations do
means like how far off from the mean you
are and we're gonna square them okay
then we're gonna add them all together
okay so we're gonna take that sum we're
gonna then divide it by how many data
points we have okay which is N and then
we're gonna take the square root and
that'll give us our standard deviation
okay so you're with me so far okay so
first thing we need to do is find the
mean okay this x-bar that's the average
so you probably already know how to find
the average you just add up all the data
points so that's five plus eight plus
eight plus nine plus ten all divided by
five data points so this comes out to 40
divided by five which equals eight so
our average score is eight so what we're
going to do is we're going to take five
minus 8 which is negative 3 8 minus 8
which is 0 8 minus 8 which is 0 9 minus
8 which is 1 and 10 minus 8 which is 2
so those are the deviations we're gonna
then square them negative 3 squared is
positive 9 0 squared is 0 0 squared is 0
1 squared is 1 and 2 squared is 4 we're
gonna add those up so that comes out to
14 we're gonna divide by how many data
points we have which in this case it's 5
okay and then what we're going to do so
this is 14 divided by 5 and we're going
to take the square root and if we do
that we get approximately one point six
seven so that's our standard deviation
and it gives us a sense of how spread
out the data points are from the mean
now the more data points we have you
know it would give us a little bit more
information we have a limited amount of
data here but just to you know
illustrate how the process works when
you're doing it by hand
so I hope you're enjoying these videos
go ahead and subscribe to the channel if
you have comments go ahead and put the
comments below I'd be interested to hear
about you know what you're studying and
how this these videos are helping you
and you know what it's helping you
accomplish whether it's a major degree
or maybe a teacher just trying to
refresh whatever it might be I'm curious
and I'll see you in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon